head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard
charts from raw's alerts running
candidate v g ramaswami has pledged to
withdraw from the Colorado GP primary
unless Trump is also allowed to be on
the state's ballot additionally has
demanded that Ronda santis Chris
Christie and Nikki Haley do the same
immediately Bravo good sir he has
basically just laid it down I mean this
is this is he's he's he's he's you
everyone's before they can blink yeah
he's making that that chess play now Ron
Chris Christi or Nikki Haley who remains
I bet they're polling drops I bet people
look at them as dishonorable for this
well look you you don't have to like
Trump but there's going to be a lot of
Republicans who are upset they don't get
a choice yes you're being told by
Colorado you don't we don't care what
you think you don't get a right to
choose V is standing up and he makes a
really great point in this long Twitter
thread V tweets this is what an actual
attack on Democracy looks like in an
unamerican unconstitutional and
unprecedented decision a cabal of
democrat judges are barring Trump from
the ballot in Colorado having tried
every trick in the book to eliminate
president Trump from running in this
election the bipartisan establishment is
now employing a new tactic to Bar him
from ever holding office again the 14th
Amendment I alleged to withdraw from the
Colorado GP GOP Primary unless Trump is
also allowed to be on the state's ballot
and I demand that Ronda santis Chris
Christie and Nikki Haley do the same
immediately or else they are tacitly
endorsing this illegal maneuver which
will have disastrous consequences for
our country today's decision is the
latest election interference tactic to
silence political opponents and swing
the election for whatever puppet the
Democrats put up this time by depriving
Americans of the right to vote for their
candidate of choice the 14th amend was
part of the Reconstruction amendments
that were ratified following the Civil
War it was passed to prohibit former
Confederate military and political
leaders from holding High federal or
state office these men had clearly Taken
part in a rebellion against the United
States the Civil War that makes it all
more absurd that left-wing group in
Colorado is asking a federal court to
disqualify the 45th president on the
same grounds equating his speech to
Rebellion against the US and there's
another legal problem Trump is not a
former officer of the United States as
that term is used in the Constitution
meaning Section 3 does not apply as the
Supreme Court explained in free
enterprise fund V public Company
accounting oversight board in 2010 quote
an officer of the United States is
someone appointed by the president to
Aid him in his duties under Article 2
Section 2 the term does not apply to
elected officials and certainly not to
the president himself the framers of the
14th Amendment would be appalled to see
this narrow provision in tended to Bar
former US officials who switched to the
Confederacy from seeking public office
being weaponized by a sitting president
and his political allies to prevent a
former president from seeking reelection
our country is becoming unrecognizable
to our founding fathers has there ever
been a time when someone was prevented
from being on a ballot in American
history I can't think I don't think it's
ever been used yeah I mean maybe not in
any legitimate like large scale kind of
way you know maybe there was like a
criminal was trying to do something and
then they made a filing I don't know I'd
imagine it think the 14th has been used
yeah not the 14 I could be wrong I'm
sure somebody on the international fact
Checkers I this statement by Vivic is is
fantastic and how fast he put that out
not just considering how much length and
and information he put in there is great
but in in politics a lot of times you
get told hey wait don't come out right
away let's test this let's see if this
is going to work out you know maybe
Trump going to take it off the ballot
it's going to be good for you let's give
it a couple days I I think this is
pretty genuine he just fired off right
away and said the stakes are too high
let's all rally around president Trump
let's rally around us actually having a
democratic process I I think that's
awesome for him and I think that's the
right way forward he did he did this
when Trump was about to go get handed in
to to New York you know he came out
right away on the phone in the backseat
right and no one else said anything that
was when I was like thought the santis
is really weak and for this and for this
if Trump for some reason is completely
unavailable V is next in line not Nikki
not Ron not Chris Christie because V has
outright said I will step aside yeah if
they keep playing these dirty games yeah
and it's and it's it's it's it's a
brilliant move let's say in the end he
removes himself from the GOP Primary and
no one else does let's say then
something happens to Trump he goes to
jail and he's for some reason unable to
do it Trump supporters will select VI
over anyone else yeah because of his
willingness to stand behind Donald Trump
100% yeah I don't see how like if aake
removes himself or whatever if Trump and
ofer removed from the running I feel
like that's a win for the uh
establishment sure there's if they start
something else I mean full moose party
that yeah that's possible too but that I
that would split and I I mean how it
split ends up splitting up you know is
anyone's guess um but I don't think that
it would be a positive right now because
they're taking Trump off the off of the
uh primary the primaries and stuff um I
don't know I mean maybe maybe they could
start another uh you know another uh
party could be I'm just going to call it
B bul Moose for now and then Republicans
and then we got Kennedy doing his thing
independent and then the Democrats like
it be interesting if they do it the Bull
Moose Party did not do well though no
unun they third parties never do I mean
the libertarian part's been you know
struggling for decades that actually
would be really funny if somehow Trump
ends up the libertarian nominee and then
the Libertarians get like 43% of the
vote and it's like well the Republicans
are gone just that's it don't worry the
Libertarians hate themselves they hate
everybody so they'd hate Trump plenty
but I would think if the 14th amember
could keep him off as a republican it
could just keep them off in general a WR
in in the general election yeah has that
ever happened has has ever been like a
massive wrri in for a candidate not at
the presid there's like six or there's
like six or nine states that you can't
write someone in I forget what Colorado
one of them I'm not sure but uh someone
was tweeting about it I retweeted it but
there's like something like nine states
where that you can't do a write in so
that means likely you know if he's not
on the The Ballad that he can't win um
at least if he's on the ballot as a as a
republican right I I just don't see I
mean I don't understand like I said
first of all I don't understand the
mechanism because he hasn't been found
guilty of anything and I feel like
unless you does apparently it does got
rid of Santos like that too yeah I mean
that's yeah Mendes is his stuff in gold
bars in his in his well but he's not
even he's not even convicted no issues
there he's not even convicted
the point we can all sit here and be
like yeah s is a bad dude but he wasn't
convicted of anything exactly and due
process doesn't matter apparently to the
Democrats this is clear and I I
challenge any of my uh left leaning or
or even left liberal friends to give me
a reason as to why the Democrats do
believe in due process seeing as you've
got Santos and this situation with Trump
I don't see any reason to believe that
anything that they say about D process
means anything at all to them so and I
don't know what that means for the you
know I obviously I don't know what that
what that means for the country this is
unprecedented it's you know totally new
territory it's clearly purely political
it's about an outsider who challenges
The Establishment whether or not you
like Donald Trump is irrelevant it's
about an outsider that the establishment
the established order disapproves of and
they're doing whatever they can to make
sure that he can't get back into into
office in you know in you know in
opposition to what the people seem to
want he is leading the polls and they're
removing him this is to call this you
know Banana Republic stuff is
insufficient the dude is walking into
like stadiums yeah exactly cheered for
and the only reason there hasn't been
some kind of more action from the public
is because because of how comfortable
Society is now I really really believe
that because life is so comtable not
necessarily easy but comfortable and
people are so sedated on whether it be
you know whether it be Pharmaceuticals
or booze and smoking weed and all those
things which look I'm not judging anyone
that does I have I have plenty of
history of all kinds of substances and
stuff like that so I'm not dogging
anyone but because of those things life
is easy life is comfortable and life is
a little on the numb side because of
that people aren't looking for it's like
a I've been saying it's like a pandemic
of complacency yeah no
why do you life is even a rough life in
the west is a good life and it's an easy
life so why do you really want to go
ahead and unless and this is probably
going to upset some people but unless
you are actually mentally ill which is
what the left seems to the more extreme
left seems to go after because those
people are the ones that are the
revolutionaries they're the people that
are upset that well this is
scientifically proven actually there's a
higher higher density of mental illness
along those among those who identify as
left leaning and so those people go and
throw you know mtop cocktails at cop
cars and for some reason we ignore that
and and just say that's i' also say a
lot of them not all of them but a lot of
them don't have kids and don't feel this
type of urgency to save the future for
children right it's all like uh the
luxury like modern luxury complacency
and stuff like that so think about when
it's the farle going insane and burning
things down and the children grow up in
the Society of violence and Chaos think
about the things they will value when
they get older they're not going to like
these people they're going to remember
the horrors that they experienced
they're going to remember their family
members killed and they're going to
they're going to understand struggle and
pain and they're probably going to be
more conservative yeah probably I mean
the data is already there I've said it
50 billion times mhm the conservatives
just have more kids now you take any kid
you take a you take the the child of
liberals and you introduce them to a
world where the farle is burning and
destroying everything these kids are
going to live like rabbits little
tightly wound balls of stress and
anxiety and they're going to despise
living in that world I hope the positive
outlook and I try to be optimistic but
it's also they could inherit complete
nihilism and not even know any better it
might take much longer for them to
understand you know a moral Center in a
lot of ways fortunately be a lot of pain
between now and that's the and also like
how what kind of establishment gets put
in place of the liberal establishment
that the Democrats are literally trying
to destroy I don't care you can they can
give all the lip service they want to
democracy they don't give a sh crap
about democracy at all and they
definitely don't care about liberalism
they've been they've been wearing
liberalism like a like a skin suit for
ages so what kind of government what
kind of of structure does it take and
and it seems that the structure is going
to be more racist less Fair it's going
to be less focused on economic growth
and more focused on it seems like it's
going to be focusing on shrinking the
not just the economy but shrinking the
population because we've got people that
are so concerned about um what in my
opinion is is climate alarmism all of
these things mean a a future that is
significantly worse than our recent past
at the very least possibly significantly
worse than any of the horrors of the of
the 20th century because if you're doing
degrowth you end up with if you end up
with population collapse you have a like
we talk about a a crisis of Competency
now when you have a a population
collapse there are entire industries
that disappear that's how you lose
knowledge because no one learns how to
do it from the people that do that do
know how to do whatever the topic is and
then when those people die that
information is lost the OR at the very
least the skill to do it well is lost
it's all gone this is the funny thing
about people who harp on conspiracies
about the moon landing and stuff
questioning how do we lose technology he
looked at me real quick I don't know if
everyone saw oh yeah did look at me it's
just fascinating that like you know
where's where's your you had a laptop
everyone listening you had a laptop five
years ago where is it go through all the
files go through your tax documents
where are your tax forms from last year
do you remember I know a lot of you
probably do a lot of people don't and
then they try to log in every year going
what was my pin and they're typing away
and they can't get in you know look you
you can't even remember where your tax
forms are you're going to remember where
some obscure documents about radiation
shielding is from 40 years ago good luck
we the the population degrowth stuff is
basically we talked about it with Alex
Jones on the show when he was talking
about ishmail the gorilla and you know
they they want people to return to a
living in the wilderness kind of
Lifestyle I mean to be fair Tucker even
said he didn't think technology was
helping us the other day MH he said you
know explain to me one technology that
made people happy or something that
effect well essentially showed the
regime that as long as you keep the
Netflix on and as long as people can get
enough money to go to the store and buy
their favorite foods they will take a
obscene amount of Oppression that I I
never would have thought was even
believable dude look at look if you can
guarantee sunny days you can absolutely
abuse your population look at what
people do and put up with in California
I mean I would go out there periodically
I've been out there a few times this
year and it is absolutely beautiful all
of the freaking time it's all it's
absolutely gorgeous all the time it's so
nice that the the government can just
absolutely abuse the population it's
super expensive taxes are ridiculous
they they've got you know obviously
you've got homeless population I saw a
video the other day from 10 years ago of
when Gavin Nome was the the uh the mayor
of San Francisco swearing up and down
that he's going to clean up the homeless
people a decade later it isn't any
better in inan Frisco it's literally
spread to the he clean it up when she
show exactly but that's the thing that
the it's it's so nice if you get up when
you wake up every day and it's
75° 350 days of the year you'll put up
with a lot of crap thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net